[Music]
It's God. It's God. It's God.
It's God
>> being God.
>> Yes sir.
>> I don't believe that if you can convince
me because I don't believe God is a man.
I believe the God the essence of God is
what makes him God.
>> Okay.
>> I don't believe there's anybody above
God.
>> Okay. I also don't believe that um I
mean God when he becomes a man that is
like a limitation because then there is
someone above him. Now
>> I don't mean to interrupt you. Go ahead
and finish that.
>> A human being cannot be God.
>> Okay.
>> And Jesus is God. So it's like I am God
and not God at the same time.
>> Do do you believe that God is all
powerful?
>> I do. But God that's what's within his
nature.
>> Okay. So, do you So, do you believe that
if God wanted to,
>> could he take on a human form if he
wanted to?
>> I don't think so.
>> Okay. So, then you don't believe he's
all powerful?
>> No. No. I do believe he's all powerful.
Now, for example, I can ask you, can God
lie? You can tell me God cannot lie.
>> No. The scripture says God cannot lie.
But your Bible says God cannot lie.
Right.
>> Not the Quran.
>> No, I know. But I'm asking you. We're
talking the context of your Bible. So if
God cannot lie and then you're going to
say, "Okay, but God is all powerful, but
he can't lie."
>> Yes. That would be a li that would
actually be a weakness. Him him lying
would actually be a flaw,
>> right? But God doesn't have flaws,
>> right? So how how is him taking on a
human nature a flaw?
>> Okay. To take on a human nature, God is
all knowing.
>> God is uh
>> he he doesn't cease to be God.
>> He does if he human beings are not all
knowing.
>> No, brother. Look. So our belief is not
that God when he takes on human nature
or takes on human form that he loses his
divine uh attributes and qualities. We
don't believe that. We we believe we
believe that he is in the incarnation
that he possesses both. He doesn't lose
the divine nature. He possesses both
now. So he's divine and human at the
same time.
>> Well, that's what I'm saying. Two
natures that contradict itself. God and
not God at the same time. Mortal and
immortal at the same time. Like for
example, you are you a physical being?
>> Yes.
>> Do you have a soul?
>> I do.
>> Is your soul physical?
>> No. So you have you are made you have a
physical quality to yourself and an
non-physical quality to yourself. Two
contradictory qualities. How does that
work?
>> They're not contradictory because my
soul is a composite of who I am. For
example, I'm Abby, right? I am a spirit
and a human being. So this it's parts
that come together to form me.
>> But contradict each other.
>> But notice how you have qualities. You
as you as as a whole being you have
qualities that that are contradictory,
right? You have a quality that is
immaterial and you have a quality that
is material.
>> How are they contradictory?
>> Because one is material and the other is
immaterial.
>> No, not necessarily. Because for
example,
>> is a soul material?
>> Wait one sec. Soul is not material. But
what I'm saying is that God is all
knowing. You agree with me?
>> Yeah. But wait, don't don't skip. We'll
get to there. I promise we can get to
that. All right. Just notice you said
how is it how is it contradictory? You
can't for something to be if something
is material,
>> it can't be material at the same time in
the same sense. Right.
>> Okay. Because it it's two companies that
comes together to form you as a being.
So your flesh cannot dwell without your
spirit.
>> So do you that's my point. You you have
qualities that oppose each other but yet
it's not contradictory as for you as a
human being as a whole. You understand
what I'm saying?
>> Okay. So let's analyze Jesus as a human
being. He has a spirit and he has a
flesh just like me. Correct.
>> Yep.
>> And he has his divine aspect as well.
>> That's right.
>> So how many natures?
>> He has two natures.
>> You see my point? So what's the problem?
>> So So his divine nature, he's all
knowing.
>> Correct.
>> His human nature is not
>> all knows and matures.
>> His human nature,
>> but he's still all knowing though. He
doesn't lose his knowledge.
>> No. Is he all knowing?
>> Jesus. So So Jesus the person is all
knowing. Now regarding his his his human
nature, he grows. He matures. He grows
in wisdom and stature. The point is is
that is pertaining to the human nature,
not the divine nature.
>> The essence of God is he already
possesses that attribute, right? He
doesn't gain those attributes. Correct.
>> He's he's possessed from the beginning.
Correct. So he doesn't grow in knowledge
because that's who he is.
>> Yeah. Correct. So do you see how do you
see how you're you're talking about his
divine nature?
>> Right. So that's why I'm saying that him
growing in knowledge and wisdom is an
attribute. Okay. Well, in wisdom is an
attribute that is not divine.
>> You agree? I I I agree that that is not
a quality of the divine nature. Correct.
This is why we're saying there's two
natures. There's the nature where those
qualities abide and then there's
properties of the human nature where
those specific qualities abide. So we're
not saying that Jesus in his divine
nature is both uh all knowing and not
all knowing at the same time in his
divine nature.
We're saying that Jesus is all knowing,
has the all knowing properties
pertaining to his divine essence, but
also pertaining to his human nature can
grow in wisdom and stature.
>> Jesus as a person has is both divine and
uh uh human as well. Those uh those
properties I mean those natures do exist
at the same time.
>> At the same time they coexist.
>> Yes.
>> So he can tap into his divine nature.
It's it's not necessarily tapping in
because look, he possesses both
properties of nature. I agree with you.
Okay. So, what I'm saying is is that
like this this is why you can see things
like um Jesus bleed for example.
Obviously, God in his divine essence
doesn't bleed. He doesn't have a
physical body, right?
>> But Jesus in his in his physical form
can bleed. He can drop a tear. He can
get hungry. But pertaining to his divine
nature, you're seeing he he doesn't like
those properties don't apply, right?
That's why he can say I give eternal
life. That's why he can say, you know,
uh to the storms and the waters, peace,
be still, and they obey his command.
>> Well, those are miracles. He says, I
give eternal life because he has
authority to give eternal life.
>> Yeah, but that's not a miracle. That's
that's that's that's a divine property.
>> But you agree that he was given
authority to give eternal life.
>> No, no, no. Does he need authority to
give eternal life?
>> But brother, can can anybody other than
God give eternal life?
>> Well, God grants the authority to
somebody to give eternal life.
>> Are you saying authority like as a
permission or power? Well, in the
essence, I mean, in the in the context
of the scripture, it could be power.
>> Oh, no. It's it's permission.
>> Okay. Permission. Does God need
permission to give eternal life at any
point?
>> Yeah. If you're talking about the son
who submits to the father, let me
finish. If you're talking about the son
who submits to the father, you can have
god the son who willfully submits to the
father and doesn't do anything outside
the father's uh prerogative. So, that's
why he doesn't move until unless the
father says move. He doesn't do anything
unless the father says do it. So it's
not that he doesn't have these powers or
abilities. It's it's almost like this.
If let's say I'm a general and you're my
sniper. Okay. Now you have the target in
sight. Right. But you don't shoot unless
I give you permission to shoot. Does
this mean that you don't have the
ability to shoot within yourself?
>> I do have the ability to shoot, but I
have to acquire that ability. Right. No,
I have to acquire because I didn't
possess it.
>> Yeah. Yeah. In in this analogy,
>> general in army, I have to train to get
a gun.
>> I'm saying in this analogy, you already
have that ability,
>> right? But my point is that without you
giving me the permission to shoot, I
can't shoot. I have to depend on you to
shoot. I I cannot be equal to you if I
need your permission.
>> You're not equal to me in what way?
>> In the sense of of authority and
>> but but we're equal in our essence,
right?
>> But if we are both answer that we're so
as human beings.
>> Exactly. So wait, wait, pause cuz let's
not go too fast. Right.
>> So we can be equal in one sense but not
equal in another. Right. That's as a
human being.
>> No, just period.
>> But but if we are both for example, we
are both kings. We have equal power. I
don't need your permission to do
something that I can do on my own.
>> I just get up and I do it. If you have
to give me permission to do it, I am not
equal to you in the sense of the
authority and the power.
>> Yeah. But that still doesn't change how
you guys how you guys are still equal in
essence but not equal in who you ser and
who you serve. Well, but in the essence
of God, his omni properties is what
makes him God. If at a point, one of his
omni property is diminished, it doesn't
make him go.
>> I agree. That's why I'm saying, look,
brother, that's what I'm saying. Jesus
is not diminished in his divinity. His
divinity does not change. Okay? Just
because he acquires a a human nature and
operates within the human nature doesn't
mean that his divine nature is now
diminished. No, he just willfully uh uh
operates within the human limitations.
For for example, according to Acts 2:36,
it says that God made Jesus Lord and
Messiah. Yeah. Now, if he is God and
he's equal to God in all aspects, why
does he need God to make him Lord and
Messiah? Do you get my point, brother?
>> I I can answer that. This is this again.
is God made Lord.
>> Yeah. Again, this is going to deal with
authority and submission, not essence.
So, look, let me hear the hear here the
answer cuz I want you to I want you to
get what I'm saying.
>> Go ahead.
>> There's a difference between the essence
and what you are and then how you
operate in relations to someone. So,
because the father and the son share the
same omni properties, they share the
same divine essence as the one god.
However, the son chooses to humble
himself to the father and he submits
himself by taking on flesh and being
born in the likeness of men. Therefore,
the father can then exalt the son back
to that position. That's why it says the
son is made lord and made messiah
because he humbled himself and is being
exalted to these positions. A position
that he let go before humbling himself
and taking on flesh. Well, you're saying
that he's of the same nature as God. He
possesses the same divine attributes as
God. But what I hear you say, I don't
come to the conclusion that he possess
the same divine attributes of God. Now,
>> why not? Wait, what about what I said?
>> One, the father is not made Lord.
>> Jesus is made.
>> What does that have to do with his
essence?
>> Well, essence is what makes God God. Do
you agree?
>> Yes. So what does what does him being
made Lord and made me Messiah have to do
with his divine
>> because God is not made Lord at any
point in time. He's always been Lord
from the beginning.
>> Well, no. So again, you're more people
or
>> after this you got to be patient. If
you're not paying attention,
that's why.
>> No, I'm enjoying this. So he doesn't
dictate this. I I dictate
>> like he's saying nothing.
>> Brother, you got to stop interrupting.
Please, please interrupt. Don't
interrupt, please.
>> No, we're just waiting.
>> So well, keep waiting. Keep waiting.
>> Sorry. No, it's all good. So anyway, so
according to what you're talking about,
you keep conflating your role and your
position with essence, your role and
position has nothing to do with your
essence. If like for example, if I make
you lord of a house, if I make you lord
of the household, does that mean that I
have not raised you as a human being?
That you wasn't human before? Well, I
was a human, but in terms of the power,
right, I don't have the power to make
myself Lord. You have to make me Lord.
>> So, that that authority is relinquished
to me, right?
>> Right. And you submit to me under that
authority. Right. So, notice how that
has nothing to do with your essence as a
human.
>> It's to do with your role.
>> Jesus being made Lord or Messiah is
role, not his essence.
>> Yeah. But what I'm saying is that even
if you focus on essence, for example,
let's um in heaven, Paul tells us in 1
Corinthians 15:24 and up, he tells us
that God subject everything under Christ
except God himself.
Now at the end,
>> father,
>> right, the father or God. Now at the
end, when Christ has conquered dominion,
authority, and power,
>> his reign will continue. and his reign
will end. His reign doesn't end, bro. It
says, Should I pull the scripture?
>> Yeah, pull it up where it says his reign
ends. What you're going to see is that
he gives everything over to the father.
>> Say that he shall reign until
>> No, it doesn't.
>> Okay, sure. Let me pull it. Uh first,
>> his reign doesn't come to any end, bro.
>> Okay, let's see. No problem.
Uh
15.
[Music]
>> Let me see if I can go to Bible.
>> Okay. So from here, can you read for
>> You can read from here if you want. You
want me to read?
>> Okay. But I'm going to read from verse
20. But Christ has indeed been raised
from the dead, the first fruits of those
who have fallen asleep. For since death
came through a man, the resurrection of
the dead comes through a man. For as in
Adam all die, so is Christ all will be
made alive. But in each 10 Christ the
first fruits, then when he comes, those
who belong to him. Then the end will
come when he hands over the kingdom to
God the Father after he has destroyed
all dominion, authority, and power. For
he must reign until he has put all his
enemies under his feet. The last enemy
to be destroyed is dead. For he has put
everything under his feet. Now when it
says that everything has been put under
his feet, it is clear that this does not
include God himself who put everything
under Christ. When he has done this,
then the son himself will be made
subject to him who put everything under
him. So that God will be all in all.
>> So where does it say that his kingdom
ends?
>> It says that his reign must you see that
what I read?
>> Yeah. His reign will continue until
everything is put everything is under
his feet. But what does it say that he
stops ruling?
>> For he must reign until he has put all
his enemies under his feet. After that
he doesn't reign no more.
>> Where does it say that?
>> It said until the word until once he put
all enemies under his feet. Let me show
you something, brother. Let me show you.
>> Let me show you.
>> You don't know what it says here.
>> It doesn't say it ends. So when you say
something, I know what you're saying.
When you say when you say something
until that doesn't necessarily mean
something ends.
>> If I say if I say if I say you're going
to keep drinking water, it's until I I I
come. What does it mean?
>> Well, I'm going to show you when I when
I come. I'm going to show you.
>> So watch this. When it come talks about
the ruling of the son of man.
>> Well, but let's let's finish this first.
>> I am. I'm showing you. We're on the same
subject. Are you listening yet?
>> We're on the same subject. So, watch
this. When we go to Daniel and we look
at the the the son's rule.
>> Let's see if his reign ends.
>> Wait. The reason why I'm saying that is
because he's going to hand over the
kingdom to God the Father. That's what
it means.
>> That doesn't mean that he stops ruling
though. He's ruling in God's kingdom
>> without the kingdom.
>> He's ruling in God's kingdom.
>> But the kingdom does not belong to him.
If he's God,
>> it still belongs to him.
>> How am I brother? I am equal to.
>> You are saying the man his essence that
it makes him God. He's equal to God. But
he's handing over the kingdom that God
gave to him to God. And then when he
does that,
>> do you see how he's still ruling in
God's kingdom?
>> Well, let me finish. My point is that
you were saying he's equal to God, but
he's handing over the kingdom to God.
And when he does that, brother, let me
just finish. Go ahead. after he hands
over the kingdom to God. It says that
God subject everything under Christ
except God himself which means God is
not under Christ. Then when the end
comes, Christ is going to be subject
under God. So that God will be all in
all. Now if you look at the Greek
context, can I respond? I'm just going
to wrap up now. If you look at the Greek
context, it says subject means
subordination, meaning he's going to be
inferior to God. This is this is heaven
where Christ has assumed all his
authority and glorified state. So he's
divine in in in heaven. Why is he
handing over God the glory? I mean the
kingdom.
>> Can I answer you with the scripture?
>> Go ahead, brother.
>> I appreciate it. So this is Daniel. It
says that one like the son of man was
coming and he came up to the ancient of
days and came near before him and to him
was given dominion, glory and a kingdom
that all peoples, nations and men
everywhere, peoples, every tongue will
serve him. His dominion is an
everlasting dominion
>> which will not be taken away.
>> Good point.
>> And his kingdom is one which will not be
destroyed.
>> So will his kingdom end?
>> Was it given to him?
>> Please. Was it Will?
>> According to I'm going I'm going to
according to this verse it's
everlasting. However, people listen.
That's what I'm telling you. According
to this verse, the kingdom is
everlasting. The dominion is
everlasting. But it was given to him
when he approached.
>> That wasn't your problem at first. No,
no, I'm going to end. I will add
I I will add that. I'm just trying to
tell you
>> in in the verse you read when he
approached the ancient of days which is
God will his kingdom end
according to the verse according to the
verse you read it says the kingdom is
everlasting but we go to the verse I
read this is yes or no bro
>> brother we have two verses one says that
he was given dominion glory and kingdom
now according to the verse you read it
says the kingdom is everlasting the
verse I gave says he's handing over the
kingdom to God the Father. Now,
>> where does it say that he stops ruling?
>> That's not what I ask. Is he handing
over the kingdom?
>> Of course. Where does it say he stops
ruling under the father?
>> Brother,
>> if if something is given to you and it's
everlasting, I'm asking it all the time.
>> I'll ask you straight. I'll ask you
straight away. You ready?
Straightforward question. Go ahead,
brother.
>> In the verse we just read you, does it
say his kingdom will end? Yes or no?
>> No, it doesn't say it will end.
>> Here's my question. Let me ask Here's
the next one. Here's the next one. In
the verse you read, does it say that
Christ will stop reigning? Yes or no?
>> It says that he's going to hand over the
kingdom to God.
>> Does it say he will stop reigning?
>> Okay. So, the verse says that he will
reign until now when you use the word.
>> If this is the case, this this is this
is done. If if you Bobby, you want to
jump in and talk to
>> One second. Just let me write up. Let me
write up.
>> Okay. Okay. Can you answer me? Cuz he
not being honest.
>> No, no, no. Let him answer me in the
last point.
>> Why is Christ Why is Christ
Why is Christ? Who is God?
>> And equal to God. He's handing over the
kingdom. God gave it to him. Now he's
going to be under God. It says God will
subject Christ under him so that God
will be all in all. But you're telling
me Christ is equal to God. He's God.
>> Why is he handing over these things to
God?
>> Okay. So you're saying that Christ is
going to be subject to God. Therefore,
he can't be equal to God. Right?
>> It's not if if I am subject
>> that same Hold on one second. That same
word is used in Luke chapter 2 verse 51
where it says that Jesus was subject to
Mary and Joseph. Does that make Mary and
Joseph greater than Jesus and Jesus
being inferior? Just a second. In Romans
13:1
>> we Christians are subject to what?
>> Controlling authorities as long as right
it doesn't contradict the law of God.
But now here's your problem.
>> Well, let me just respond. We're hold on
just a second. Because that's what
subject means. So subject cannot mean
inferiority.
>> Not in every sentence,
>> right? So then not in this either. Do
you know why? Focus on the not in this
one either. Let me tell you why. The
reason why that is is because in 1
Corinthians 15 24-28 in that context,
Christ destroys the last death, which of
the last enemy, which is death. It says
that
>> Hosea 13:14 says, "Yahweh does that, and
Yahweh does that alone." Number one.
Number two, what does it mean that God
will be all in all? What does that mean?
God will be all in all. all because for
the purpose of his mission, God gave him
the kingdom. This is why he says,
"Brother, let me just respond. I have
come to proclaim the good news of the
kingdom of God." So now when he's
finished his mission, he's standing over
the kingdom to God. God will be all in
all. My my response is not about that.
My response is that one question
brother. My response is that according
to the Greek, it says the subject means
subordination. Now I don't take one word
and generalize the meaning across both.
I focus the context in which it's used.
It says that everything was sub
everything was subject under Christ
which means everything was inferior
under Christ for the purpose of his
mission. But when he completes his tax
he hands over to God. Then God subjects
everything under him. But one thing is
that God was not subject under Christ.
Christ is subject under God which he say
subordination. If he's equal to God, why
is he being subordinate under God?
>> Beautiful. So number one, you still have
to answer what does it mean that God
will be all in all? Because actually,
hold on. If you actually understand the
commentators of what they say about
these Bible verses, it simply means that
the priesthood ends when the last enemy,
death, is destroyed by Christ. So
there's no more priesthood anymore. Now
Christ, who's not going to be needing to
intercede on our behalf anymore because
we'll all be made morally incorruptible
and physically indestructible.
Therefore, we have no need for a priest.
God will be all in all. Now again, what
does it mean that God will be all and in
all? Please answer that question.
>> Well, that's why I told you the way I
understand is that the kingdom was given
to Christ. You remember it says all
authority in heaven and earth was given
to me. He also says that I have come to
proclaim the good news of the kingdom of
God. So he was sent for example in
Matthew 12:28 God said
>> brother you're not answering the
question.
>> I'm I'm answering just I would just
answer let me I mean just just give me
the point please. He says brother
brother I will answer you. I'm giving
you I'm giving you an opportunity to
engage.
>> I like to
>> you have to answer straight away.
>> I like to answer but I I I want but
you're not to make sense.
>> Okay. So this answer first and then
elaborate. You understand?
>> Okay. So I mean God what does it mean
that God is all in all?
>> Okay. Because the kingdom God gave it to
Christ. That's why I just said the way I
understand it. God gave the kingdom to
Christ for the purpose of his mission
and power.
>> Can Christ be all in all?
>> One second. Once he's finished the tax,
he's he hands over the kingdom back to
God. So now God has the full kingdom
which makes him all in all. That's the
way I understand. Now if you understand
it differently, you can enlighten me on
it. But what I'm saying,
>> can a human being can a human being be
all and in all?
>> What?
>> Oh, you have to give me an example. But
this is what this you brought up the
verse.
>> Yeah, but here it says God will be all
in all. But
>> so what does it mean all and in all?
>> Can we can we focus on my point rather?
This is the point and you brought this
up.
>> My point is not God in all in all. My
point is he's subject under God. That's
my point.
>> My point here is that you're coming to a
verse to try to show that Jesus is not
God because he's subject to the father
in the kingdom so that God may be all in
all. So if you're coming to this as an
objection to the deity of Christ, you
need to understand tell us what it means
to be God to be God to be all in all.
Can a can anybody other than God be all
in all?
>> The like I told you the verse says God
will be all in all. Now, if you know
something else,
>> can anybody be God? Can anybody be all
or no?
>> That's what I'm just trying to tell you.
>> Yes or no?
>> What I know is what I'm telling you.
>> So, is that a yes or no or you don't
know?
>> I just told you that according to this,
I don't know. I don't know anybody who
can be all by the cont
11. Christ is all and in all. This is no
mere human attribute. Just number one.
>> Okay. Well, hold on one second. all and
in all.
>> Okay. What the context I want to talk
about that in just a moment. Number two,
I noticed that you also brought up for
example Luke 2 verse 52 that Jesus grew
in wisdom.
>> No, I didn't bring that. He brought it
up.
>> Okay. So, he grew in wisdom, right? And
straight up, not me.
>> Okay. Now, do you have a problem with
Jesus growing in wisdom and stature?
>> Well, let's stay on top. Let's we will
stay on top because the same Luke also
says about Jesus. Jesus says it about
himself that the wisdom of God sends out
prophets.
Can Jesus be the wisdom of God? Can a
human being be the wisdom of God?
>> Um I mean if God subject everything
under Christ of course then that makes
sense
>> because it says that God subject
everything under Christ except God
himself for the purpose of his. So that
would make sense.
>> Human being to be the wisdom of God
>> because who who sent him? God sent him
>> the wisdom of God. If God sent him,
well, Christ says that the words I speak
unto you are not mine. My father command
me to say all the things I spoken.
>> So is using God's wisdom or is he
>> So God is speaking through him.
>> So is he God's wisdom or is he using
God?
>> Okay, it's a title. It's not that he
personally is God's wisdom.
>> I see it as a says that he sends out
prophets. Jesus says he sends out
prophets.
>> Paul says that Christ is wisdom of God.
In in Proverbs, he says wisdom. He He's
speaking. He says, "I was the first
thing the Lord brought forth as what?
The first of his works."
>> Whoso wisdom was created as friend.
That's not being God's wisdom astray.
>> Shall we go there? Shall we go there?
You would see Proverbs 8:22 is not going
to help. So, that's why I'm saying.
So, did you have a did you have a
problem with Jesus receiving from the
>> brother? And no, no, I don't have a
problem. My problem is that
>> you said you he's giving this he's
giving this king. He's giving this.
>> Yeah. My problem is that when we're
talking about his human nature, right?
All the things you brought up which I
maybe had an objection but now we went
to a verse where we come to end where in
heaven
Jesus being given the kingdom given
things
>> not kingdom
>> power authority.
>> Yes.
>> So you so you have a problem so you have
a problem with Jesus being given things
but but so if he's given things that
he's not God.
>> Why are we diverting though? You're not
answering my question. your objections.
When you bring up objections, then we
address them directly. And don't say,
"Oh, why are we switching topics?"
You're you brought up all these things.
You brought up, let me talk. You brought
up Jesus being given things. You brought
up Jesus not being God, not being all in
all and in all. So these things were
bringing up to you and you're saying,
"Oh, you're running. We're talking a
different subject." So we're asking you
things based on what you objected to.
You understand?
>> Okay. Can I respond?
>> Do you understand that?
>> Yeah, I do understand. Let me deal with
the objection.
>> Let me respond to you. So is it a
problem that Jesus
>> Let me let me respond. When I say Jesus
was given things, you appealed to his
human nature. So then I ascended to the
road where he's in heaven now. He has
assumed his full glorified state as a
god. I never said wait brother you
again. I never said appealing to his
human nature. What I said was is I'm
appealing to his human his uh humility.
I said in his humility he gives up
certain privileges and which is why he
can be exalted back to the status he is.
Please get that correctly. That's what
I'm talking. What about in heaven? Okay.
What about in heaven? Right.
>> So I need I need him to give you running
away from the things he question. Please
hold on. What about in heaven? Why is
Jesus giving things? Right?
>> Can you answer my question?
>> Okay. Hold on one second. Why is Jesus
giving things in heaven?
>> Why are we pivoting though? That's not
my focus is not giving things in heaven.
It says that he will be subject under
God. Which is subordination. Why is he
being subject under God? God wait. Is a
is a woman subject under her husband?
>> What?
>> The Bible says that the head of the
household is the man. So the head of the
man is Christ. The head of Christ is
>> answer the question. Is a woman subject
to
>> the woman is not God.
>> Is she subject to her husband?
>> Yes.
>> Is she still a human?
>> Yes, she's a human.
Oh,
wait. Wait, wait, wait. Let me finish
this. Let me finish. Let me finish this
up.
>> Let me let me finish. Let me finish this
up. So, notice this. Notice the goalpost
shift. Notice the goalpost So So,
do you understand how do you understand
how being subject to something has
nothing to do with your essence? Do you
understand that?
>> It does, actually.
>> Okay. So, she's not as human as her
husband is.
>> Wait, God is a spirit. Do you agree?
>> Answer the question. Is she just as
human as her husband?
>> She's a human being as a husband.
>> Oh, so it doesn't have anything to do
with
>> Wait, she's subject to the to her
husband because the Bible says so.
>> Is she not as human as her husband?
>> I answered you. She's a human being now.
Wait, focus.
>> Why? She don't want me answer.
>> I promise you. I promise you I will give
you
45 seconds to go uninterrupted. I answer
you making me repeat myself.
>> Cuz you need to cuz you don't hear
yourself. The reason why I'm having you
repeat yourself because you need to hear
what you're saying.
>> I did hurt you, brother.
>> So, you just said that subjectivity does
not change your nature. It doesn't
affect your nature.
>> I'm not talking about nature. I'm not,
brother. I'm not talking about nature.
I'm talking about God's essence. God,
what does that say, brother?
For example,
the nature, brother, let me
for example, the properties the
properties of God, right? Includes his
actions. Do you agree? is what makes him
is that what makes him God? I just told
you the omniresence of God is what makes
him God of his essence. You agree?
>> I just answered you. Essence is what
makes God God.
>> You're not the word.
>> What is essence?
>> Essence is the properties of God that
makes him God. So it's it's the
properties of what? You're just saying
God. What is God?
>> I just told you how many properties. Now
for example,
>> what is a nature?
>> Nature is your existence. For example,
you're a human being as essence. Now,
for example, God, let me answer now.
>> Oh my god.
>> Jesus, I'm trying to help you.
>> Jesus says in the Bible, God is spirit.
Do you agree?
>> Look at you trying to switch now.
>> I'm not switching.
>> So stay focused. We pivot all the way.
Stay focused. Stay focus. Talking. Do
you have a human essence?
>> Point. I do have a human nature.
>> Do you have a human nature?
>> Yes, I do have a human nature.
>> Okay. Does your wife have a human
nature?
>> Yes, my wife.
>> Does you have a human essence? Yes.
>> Okay. Is she subject to you?
>> My wife is subject to me.
>> Okay. Is she Is she a Does he have a
lower human essence or human nature than
you do?
>> My wife is My wife doesn't have a low
lower human nature
>> or essence, right?
>> Or essence. Now,
>> so hold on.
>> Okay. Wait one second. Notice how I walk
with you. Let me ask you. So, so
according watch this.
>> You're not letting me talk.
>> Look, I didn't let you talk. Your whole
point was that Jesus can't be God
because he's subject to the father. God
can't be subject. So therefore, Jesus
isn't God. So notice this. Stop.
Stop. You got to listen, bro. You got to
listen. Listen to your own argument.
Listen to your own argument. Your
argument is is that Jesus is not God
because he's subject to the father. God
cannot be subject. Correct?
>> God is not subject under God.
>> Is that your argument? Yes. What I'm
trying to Now, pause here. Pause here.
You don't let me talk. You just notice
he didn't argument. Obviously,
>> yeah, but he's dictating.
>> So, notice it. Stop running from
yourself. So, notice you just said that
your argument has to do with the
subjectivity of Christ not having the
divine essence, the divine nature of God
because he's subject to the father. So,
your argument has to do with essence and
nature. So, don't say you're not arguing
essence and nature. Stop. Stop. Listen.
Listen. Listen. Listening to you. So
according
>> I'm listening to you.
>> So So according to your
>> I'm listening to you finish.
>> All right. So listen. Go ahead.
>> So according to your argument, it just
fell flat because you just acknowledged
that even though a woman is subject to
her husband, that that doesn't mean that
she is diminished in her essence or
nature as a human being that she is
equally a human being like her husband
is even though she is in subjection to
her husband. So subjectivity answer this
question. This I'm going to land with
this.
>> Can I say something?
>> Subjectivity has no effect on your
nature or essence. Correct?
>> Subjectivity
has influence on who you are, your
nature, your essence. Now God is God
because of what? His essence. Now you
are saying that brother wait brother you
see watch your head. Watch your hands.
Watch your hand.